oh now I make money below another epic
installment of carpool karaoke on The
Late Late Show with James Corden this
time with cardi B who absolutely slayed
some of her biggest hits like I did a
Bar Mitzvah not so long ago my BJ he
didn't had the clean version Oh No are
you serious and I just felt so awkward
like but those kids were having a good
time of course this is car D so you know
there were some hilarious cardi moments
[Music]
party also got a driving lesson which
didn't go so hot start tearing it back
this way
you reckon yeah turns out car D is much
better behind the mic than behind the
wheel here's what happened when she
showed up to an exercise class for
senior citizen it's been a big year for
car D with music and motherhood she
opened up to et about life with her five
month old daughter culture I love
everything about motherhood I like I
like everything like it's just a
different feeling like right now my baby
she's a little sick right yeah she is
she got a little cold stuffy nose but no
fever though okay yeah so it's just like
those little things this is like it's a
new experience for me because it's like
I'm up all night I'm sucking her boogers
I'm making sure that she's breathing I'm
making sure that she don't suck on the
pacifier when the nose and the
stuffiness at the same time it's a lot
but I love everything
[Music]
you